こんにちは、どこかの誰かです。
※非公式なのでご了承下さいd(>∇<；)ゆるちて♪※
こんにちは日本を誇るTOPスパイ
、、、、、、、、、、、、、、、、、、、、、、、、
HA★
THE★
、、、、、、、、、、、、、
RYUUTAROU★　DA★
お前たちスパイの基本を分かっているか？
バカヤロー！
なんでスパイはスパイをするのか、その基本は
帽子（アウぅッ）はじめ（ドヤ顔★）
情報収集だ
バレずにどこまで潜入するか
潜入して何をするか
情報を聞き出すためだ
俺達はものを盗む盗賊ではない
こーなんかー人をヤっちゃったり
そーいうなんかー危ないこともしなぁい
俺たちスパイはなぜスパイをするのか
その理由は
極秘の情報を手に入れるためだ
そんな俺達君たちもスパイだからね？
※設定上は※
そんな俺達スパイに必要なのは
こちら
トランシーバー
トリニティートランシーバー
３色セットで３人で遊べる
遊びじゃねえ！
遊びでやって　遊びでやってんじゃないよぉ！
こっちは
ssssssssしぃごとでやってんだよぉ
んでこのトランシーバーを使うと
なんと
３０ｍまで通信が可能みたいだ
ガサッ
おぉーお
ポイ　箱（いやぁん）
ペリペリピキッキ
おぉ～（２回目）
スタッ
おぉ～（３回目）
ohohoh
トランシーバー３つ出てきましたね
とりあえず１っかい電池を挿れてみましょう
これで一応通信はできるはずです
どうやってするんだろう
え、HIKARU,HIKARU
HikaruGamesか
おぉーお（５回目）
すげえ普通に伸びるｗｗｗ
ライトボタン電源スイッチ
！”＃＄％＆’（））（’＆％＄＃”！”＃＄％＆’
これで一応電源は入ってるんでトークボタンを押してマイクスピーカに向かって喋って下さい
ジャアボクチョットエッ
トランシーバー（ドンキーに売ってるお）
まってまってちょちょちょちょちょ
うぇ
わーいわい
近づくとやっぱダメだね
ボーボボです
しゅぱっ
北、汚い音が
やめろ！ｗｗ
青いトランシーバー持って離れていくんで、声が聴こえるか聞いてて下さい
イッテキマス
あ、あーあー♂
きこえますか？×２
きこえてたねぇ
あーあぁーこれチャント出来てるんだ
よかった、これドンキーで買ったからまじ、イカれポンチかもおもったけど
ちゃんと出来るみたいですね
とゆわけで、このトランシーバーを大量に買いました
さぁーここではじめクイズ！
はじめは、日本昔ばなし出たことがある○か☓か
せいかいはー？！？！？
twitterできいてみるといいかもねｗｗ返信帰ってくると思うよ？
合計２１個のトランシーバーを準備しました
1つに3つしかHz数みたいなのが
合ってないのかなと思ったのですけど
みたところこういうHz数
の設定とかが無いし
これ自体にも何か周波数
合わせられる部分がないので多分全部共通で
同じ周波数で音が繋がってるのかなと思ったんですよ
無いよね？多分何にも書いてないから
そうだ！
というわけでこのトランシーバー全部繋がってます
だから黄色と黄色も繋がっているはずです
ザー
ほら、あー　あーああー繋がってる繋がってる　はい
ハイ見てください同じ
ずんちゃんずんちゃんずんちゃんずんちゃんずんちゃんずんちゃんずんちゃんずんちゃん
おーれははじーめ
むしろおーれはマジーめ
スタバあーいラーブユ
あそこかーゆーい
そ・ら・ち・ぃ